was a construction worker before russia
invaded ukraine
when the war started he volunteered as a
civilian evacuation driver
he is now
missing feared dead
this video shows him after he had
rescued civilians from the besieged town
of pophasna
in the east of the country
igor was his co-driver on that day he
says sergey told him if he could save
another 20 people his life would not be
in vain
i could see the entrance to papasna
russian soldiers suddenly jumped out
from the left it happened so fast they
fired a rocket-propelled grenade but it
missed then they started shooting
machine guns and rifles
the windows shattered sergey kept
driving but he was hit and began falling
dragging the steering wheel to the left
we veered off the road crashing through
small trees
i was crouched down pushing up against
the dashboard i looked at sergey and he
wasn't moving or making any sound
i reached for the door handle jumped out
and started running between the trees
using the bus as cover
they continued shooting at it when i got
to a village i found a house and got
water i was covered in blood my face my
hands and ears i thought it was mine but
i had no wounds i realized then it was
it's not known exactly how many people
are either trapped inside porpuzna or
unwilling to leave a town that is under
near constant russian army attack
is volunteer evacuation driver mikhail
pankov having a blindfold taken off on
russian state tv
two days after he disappeared while also
trying to evacuate people trapped in
pophasna only civilians are doing the
evacuation he tells the man in military
uniform interviewing him
his daughter made an emotional plea on
facebook for his release
i beg you please giving my father back
we miss him so much please release him
let him go
in a village neighboring pophasna the
sound of artillery crashes through the
air
volunteers helena and yuri inspect the
graves where they have been burying
civilians killed in the besieged town
long trenches have been dug in which
bodies lie covered in soil
a tractor will fill in the trench when
the shelling dies down
there is more danger the shells can land
on you here it is over our heads we bury
them here because it's impossible to
bury them under the shelling it's too
dangerous to go in and collect the
bodies now
i feel great pity for people killed
if they're alive now they could be doing
something good it's very hard to
comprehend when you find a young person
lying dead on the ground
ukrainian authorities say dna testing
will be done when the war ends to
identify the growing number of
unidentifiable civilians killed
this is one of three unidentified graves
in this graveyard all that's written
on the cross is that a woman's body is
buried here
and the place where that body was found
for now the fighting in popular rages on
making it too dangerous for rescuing the
living or the dead
john stratford al jazeera rubika eastern
ukraine